we are about to go and climb a glacier
as some of you guys know
climbing a glacier for me was one of the
coolest things that i've ever done so
i'm so excited to be able to do this
again i hope i survived
so
oh
okay just lean backwards that's the east
okay that's easier backwards all right
okay are you sure this is on it doesn't
matter it's too far now
okay
continue doing a good job
oh my goodness
i think i might wait for jenna
okay
let's get jenna oh gosh he's on his way
down
you can do it
i was the first one to go and i didn't
even
realize what i was doing but now we're
gonna go through here
do you want me to grab that or something
oh
it's okay keep your feet keep your feet
in jen and jump and like jump
that was us earlier
am i am i still recording
i can't see it down
all right let's go okay let me go in
front of you or you go forward
go ahead
oh my god
you